hello there Steve's cafe again and I
have a real treat today in that I'm
gonna be talking to my son whom I follow
on Twitter because he is an often-quoted
expert on certainly some of the aspects
of the whole brexit issue and since I'm
a bit confused about brexit I'm gonna
ask Eric some questions so first of all
Eric what I see from your research and
from comments that you're retweeting is
that even though there is fifty thousand
or however many thousand people
demonstrating in London in favor of
staying in the European Union
essentially the 52 percent half the
population of the UK that voted in favor
of brexit are still pretty well
committed to brexit is that correct
Froese sorry
say that again because the screen froze
go ahead oh yeah so yeah they've done
some polling since the vote and that's
shown that something like 95 percent of
those who voted to leave are pleased
with that vote and there's only a very
small number who were remorseful maybe
three four percent but equally on though
of those who voted remain there's a
couple of percent that would you know
would have changed their vote to leave
so in a way it's not really changed much
in terms of the picture I should point
out that you are a professor of
political science at Birkbeck College
the University of London and that you do
a lot of work with demography and
analyzing different groups in society
and their positions and so forth and
maybe reasons why people behave certain
ways and so forth and so on
what have you found insofar as what
motivates people one way or the other
what kinds of people tend to want to
leave the European Union what kinds of
people tend to want to remain yeah well
this is there's two kind of big
arguments one is that it's about
people's material interests and whether
if they're poor they voted against voted
in favor of leaving the EU because they
weren't felt they weren't getting any of
the benefits
and if they were wealthier they voted to
remain because that's where their
self-interest lies and part of my
argument is that that difference about
whether you're rich or poor has
virtually no effect had virtually no
effect on somebody's decision whether to
vote brexit or not it's much more to do
with cultural values whether you are
essentially liberal or conservative or
somewhat use the terms open or closed in
terms of cultural values really so how
would you how do you describe someone so
what's typically a person whose job it
was open or has more liberal cultural
values what sort of attitudes what sort
of positions do they take I mean try and
explain this I don't know you understand
the difference between I do so so you
traditionally there's been this
left-right divide between people who on
the Left who want to have more taxation
and redistribution of wealth and on the
right who want a smaller state more free
enterprise less tax that's kind of the
old division the new division is
essentially it doesn't matter whether
you are left to right what's more
important is whether you are whether you
like novelty change and diversity or
whether you prefer continuity stability
certainty and and tradition so that's
kind of the new and that cuts across so
you can have somebody who might be a
manual worker who's maybe left-wing in
terms of wanting more union power or
redistribution of wealth but who is in
favor of tradition national identity and
is against immigration so that kind of
person would be seems culturally
conservative and that would be a brexit
voter
okay now the brexit vote brexit voter is
someone who wants stability it seems to
me that the whole brexit referendum and
now the process of negotiating a deal
and nobody knows what that deal is going
to be insofar as access to the market
and and control of immigration and so
and so on and political instability in
fact it's it's a bigger adventure it
introduces more instability so why are
these people who create
stability voting in favor of the unknown
yeah but I think there are more
interested in coach the stability of
their identity in their country and
their national identity over time the
cultural stability they're not as I
don't think the economic stability and
many of them don't perceive all this
instability because they're not seeing
the value of their property drop a lot
or their stock portfolio I mean they're
not really wealthy people I'm sorry
that's not we're gonna I apologize they
get them occasionally here the idea that
their country yes so they're much more
worried that their country has changed
beyond recognition and that the things
that they take comfort from are shifting
under their feet they're much more
worried about that kind of stability
than they are about a little bit of
economic stability instability hmm do
you think that's some of the same
motivation that pushes people to vote
for Trump no matter how ridiculous his
statements are I think identical exactly
the same it's exactly the same profile
this so for example people who are in
favor of capital punishment who are
skeptical of climate change who are sort
of skeptical if they liberal elite who
would think that it's more important to
discipline children and to let them
explore you know that kind person is
simply going to be much more likely to
vote brexit and drunk and trunk yes and
so and there so a lot of the attention
focuses on things that are visible rich
poor young educated not educated that's
actually less much less important than
the invisible differences however I did
see the statistics that showed that the
degree of support for remaining was
highest amongst a sort of twenty to
thirty year olds like even seventy five
percent and then it dropped to fifty
five percent for the 30 to 50 year olds
and then those older than 50 were much
stronger in favor of brexit yeah so it
does nothing it doesn't matter it does
make some difference right but there's
still
30% of the under 25s or so that voted
for brexit right and so and if you look
at if you break it down even if you
control for take two individuals who are
25 years old male white the differences
between them is more important than the
differences between them and an older
person so it's the it's the invisible
attitude and personality differences
which count for about three three to
four times more than the invisible
things such as age class and so on and
you could argue that the people over 50
are by nature more concerned about
stability continuity tend to be a little
more authoritarian whereas the young
people are more adventurous and wanting
to explore to to some extent being
poorer being rural being older less
educated will increase your tendency
towards what's called authoritarianism
which i think is a poor word but desire
for stability will be increased but
that's but that only explains about 10%
of someone's desire for stability it's
still not largely demographic so the
threat to this sense of their you know
some sense stable sense of identity was
the threat perceived to be the fact that
Brussels had too much power and was
interfering in their lives or the
emigration from the EU or the emigration
from non EU sources so where is the
threat to their stability well I think
the the for most of the people loss of
sovereignty to the EU actually was not
very important and you could see that
because the the issue of Europe has
always had a low salience which means
it's one of the in terms of when people
are asked what's the most important
issue for you it always ranked pretty
low because most people don't even know
what it is they don't I'll wait here
again for the hour Skype connection to
improve hello Eric I'm waiting it's
frozen again hello yeah yeah okay start
again we'll have we'll have a few scenes
of you freeze
in the interview that's okay not a
problem
all right so so you said low salience
for this whole issue of the Brussels
operty so yeah so sovereignty and the
powers that the EU is taking from
Britain is was not a major issue right
it was the only people that was an issue
for worthy neat I leave campaign
particularly Boris Johnson and some of
the individuals you may or may not have
heard of such as you know anyway you may
or may not have heard of go however you
pronounce his name not so much yet Govan
people like douglas Carswell Hannon so
anyway that fired them up but for the
mass of the voters it was about
immigration and I'd say equal amounts
East European and non-european
immigration both of those things see one
thing that strikes the foreign observer
like me is that getting out of the
European Union doesn't increase or
decrease or affect the ability of
Britain to controlled non-european
immigration yeah I think that's why
except for the fact you could have
transiting by a third country so it
could be the case that people might come
from let's say Syria to Germany and then
come over to Britain and in reality that
wasn't happening if anything a European
Union was a bit of a buffer almost like
you have that camp in calais and so
forth that it was kind of protecting
Britain from this onslaught if that was
the concern and and I saw statistics
that showed that non EU immigration in
fact was declining and you pointed out
at one point too that the increase in
sort of non-white call it citizens of
the UK was more a function of higher
birth rates than increased immigration
yeah I think so I think however in the
public mind like some of the posters
that Nigel Faraj is leader of the
far-right party called the UK
Independence Party was showing posters
of long lines of migrants I know how
many suggesting that you know without a
control over immigration these people
could simply flow into Britain which is
not
but essentially they played up these
fears and in in the minds of most of
their voters they didn't necessarily
make these fine distinctions between
European non-european now the of course
there's many arguments you know one of
the you mentioned that Nigel Faraj and I
don't understand myself like Nigel
Farraj was not in fact a leader of the
lead campaign but he's probably the
strongest and longest standing critic of
the European Union with a degree of
spleen and vindictiveness and anything
he says he's almost spitting blood when
he mentions the word Union so he's the
strongest opponent but he was in fact
not leader of the the leader of the
leave campaign the leader of the lead
campaign was Boris Johnson who people
now claim at heart actually was a
remainer all right eight
welcome to he was I think he was
probably a sort of fence-sitter I don't
think he had strong views either way
right he but he was kind of he speaks I
don't know if he speaks European
languages but he certainly knows quite a
bit about other European countries and
has a kind of very multi ethnic
background and he's quite comfortable in
Europe and why was he leading the leave
campaign
what's that was he not the leader of the
lead campaign he was the leader is one
of the I wouldn't say the leader but
probably the most prominent spokesman if
fronting the campaign and which was
consisted of really two wings the Faraj
wing which was not was the unofficial
campaign whose job it was largely to
beat the bushes in some of these rural
areas and he did probably manage to
rouse more people to the polls because
there was quite a high turnout in some
of these depressed constituencies that
often have low turnout and actually
turned out in large numbers and that
helps the leave campaign but in any case
Johnson yeah I mean he partly was making
a political calculation that he could
become maybe I mean of course he later
dropped out of the race but the
calculation might have been that he
could be Prime Minister by riding the
well we have another moment here of
frozen connect
but hopefully it'll there we go okay
next question it strikes me that
so people are resentful like there's all
these undoubtedly exaggerated but still
you know increased anecdotes of people
you know saying nasty things to Spanish
polish in other ways both to
non-european origin you know call them
non-white immigrants and or to people
speaking you know a European language
and stuff like that now they're zooming
to some extent there was that I mean the
resentment if there is resentment must
and then I presume it's not like totally
dominant all over British society but
there were elements that felt that way
has that do you really feel that that
the incidence or that the amount of
aunty foreign feeling in the UK has
dramatically risen since brexit now
again we're frozen here a bit and wait
for it to unfreeze yeah did you hear me
yeah I did I don't think I mean there's
there have been more reports of those
comments or I'm not sure about attacks
but they've been more comment I think
there might have been a brief you know a
brief flurry of that but I don't think
it's really evident certainly not on the
streets of London and I think again I
would be surprised if there is a lot of
it going on so yeah I think probably
some people who used it as a license to
to to maybe make it commit comments but
I don't think it's anything yeah it's
too bad that are yeah like one thing I
noticed Eric and I'll talk is I think
your screen is frozen now but you can
hear me right no worse doctor hello
okay oh yeah so I mean when I was in
London if I go to a restaurant everybody
working there is some kind of European
basically Spanish is talking in Polish
I mean basically they were there
everywhere so no I gathered Theresa may
who's one of the candidates for the
leadership of the Conservative Party is
saying the status of these au citizens
in the UK is can't be taken for granted
or
or something so it suggests that those
people may not be able to stay or what's
kept what's actually gonna happen there
or do we just not well I think they I
think they will be able to stay but I do
think that Teresa main looks like she's
going to be emerging as the leader of
the Conservatives and thus the Prime
Minister given the fragmentations right
you can't call a political system longer
term negotiations with you and so you
know they have has to think about what
bargaining chips she holds in those
negotiations right and this is one
bargaining chip presumably now I think I
don't have any doubt in the world that
that the status of all these you people
that are already in the country is fine
but it's still I think something that
she's probably wielding as a way of
trying to get leverage on the EU because
the EU is claiming various things that
they're gonna going to drive a hard
bargain so I think Brittany's deaf some
some cards to play okay but but the
counterpart to that is all the EU all
the British citizens who live have homes
in France and Spain and so forth and so
on I mean you can't really hold these
people as hostages to the negotiation I
mean isn't it more about things like
access to British markets for German
cars or British access to European
markets or even the whole issue of
Britain's role as a financial center
insofar as European financial markets
are concerned I mean why do the people
like it seems to me a little bit cynical
and probably empty as you're confirming
to hold out these people is some kind of
a bargaining chip yeah she's taking some
stick on that I don't think that'll last
but I think ultimately it comes down to
these negotiations which will be
essentially about how much you're gonna
trade your access to the single market
for some control over free movement and
I suspect the final deal will be almost
free market access and almost free
movement so I don't and so I think that
will be a final deal
you know some area to that I think there
won't Britain won't get control of its
borders and yes and that would be maybe
put to the people
but so in the end you started out by
saying that the real the whole
sovereignty the role of Brussels issue
Brussels was not very important to
people but in the end they'll end up
with a deal that is not very different
from what they have now yeah exactly
yeah it will be very similar and so what
will happen is you're gonna get and it's
already building this sense of being
sold out right it will occur amongst the
ferocious right rump of the leave vote
but it's the leave vote was fifty two
percent so maybe in that fifty two
percent you know if forty five percent
of that or forty percent of that is
driven by immigration and you've still
got about five to ten percent perhaps
that is really about sovereignty and
we'll way to go here sorry Eric
I might get hello all right
hi you know what I am when we finished
this I can get a nanny
our granddaughter my granddaughter your
niece to go in and she can edit out the
parts where your face is all kind of
contorted in okay we'll clean it up so
yeah so they may end up more or less
with what they have now more or less on
the Norway model yeah pretty much a
Norway model may be a little some
guarantee that if the numbers go over
some ceiling that Britain will be able
to then control some sort of controls on
free movement that are very symbolic and
very limited now one other issue you
said that people once the people
discover that in fact the control on
immigration whether the EU origin non EU
origin is gonna be not very different
from what it is now like ninety five
percent the same that people will feel
they've been sold a bill of goods
is there any reaction to the fact that
these promises like 350 million pounds
of the health system and well first of
all these pictures of hordes of people
coming in and in fact that hasn't
changed and in fact and I saw interviews
on the BBC or whatever's network where
happen and whatever the guy his name was
was claiming well we never said that
we'd be controlling and then there's 350
million pounds of the National Health
System is not gonna happen and and I saw
study summer too that showed that in
fact the younger working age EU
immigrants are less of a burden on the
health system in fact they you know
taxes in versus benefits that they take
out there are better performers in the
average of they somewhat older you know
call it the British society as a whole
so actually they benefit the health
system which I can understand because a
30 year old pole is not going to be on
the health system as much as a 65 year
old you know I think that's fairly well
documented but I think it's not about
it's not really benefit materials that's
part of my majority ethnic group not
wanting to decline so so therefore
though if I interrupt so therefore Faraj
--is posters with hordes of Syrians or
something wanting to come in the country
was a much more persuasive ad than 350
million pounds to the health system yeah
I think so absolutely I mean I think the
350 was more people will take that and
they'll believe that but it's not what
drove them right drove them
fundamentally was about values you know
and yes so what will happen eventually
is that when they see that there's no
change a lot of those disgruntled people
will go to Faraj and away from the you
know some of them are Tory voters some
of them are labour voters but I think
that Faraj will benefit but he doesn't
have enough he might have 30 percent or
35 so it's not enough to scuttle a deal
so is he then that in the
that the UK Independence Party will just
get stronger and stronger
well they'll become like the pronation
I'll light the PVV and the Netherlands
where there'll be a significant party I
think protest party but they won't be
enough to to come into government and of
course in Britain there's the
first-past-the-post system which heavily
disadvantages a party like you Kip so
they won't be able to get many seats
even if they have 30% of the vote
there's they're not gonna be able to
have have many seats the PVV
has a lot of seats because of this
voting system now I'll ask you to dip
into another area of your expertise and
that is because you have written a book
on the Orange Order and you've spent a
lot of time in Northern Ireland
and one of the issues is potential
second referendum in Scotland
and also if the border between Northern
Ireland and the Republic becomes the
border between the EU and and Britain
then I saw where there was a rush on
Irish passports in like that and of
course the Catholics in Northern Ireland
are gonna use this as a drum they can
beat on to unite with Ireland what's
gonna happen in your view up north there
between Scotland and Northern Ireland
well the Scotland things quite quite
interesting of course Scotland they some
of the polls that I've seen show
somewhere between 52 and 59 percent now
say they're in favor of independence in
the polls which is actually you know
which is considerably higher which well
the polls up until the referendum when
the independence movement lost fifty
five forty five still showed a slight
majority of Scots saying that they would
vote for independence so in a way they
almost need to be on sixty percent to be
guaranteed an out vote right and they're
kind of on the cusp of that but the
problem is that now the EU has because
of Spanish pressure Spain because
the Catalans doesn't want to set a
precedent so that's the EU top brass
have essentially cold shouldered
sturgeon in the Sandia's Scots and so in
a way any hope that they could simply
unilaterally just join the EU has been
dashed the UK has to sign up to this
article negotiate its position and only
then will the Scots come in and then
they're going to be in the back of the
line so essentially they're looking at
an indefinite period even if they did
get the vote that means a sturgeon is
going to be unable to tell her
supporters that were automatically in
the EU and it'll happen quickly so it's
it's gonna be hard route harder than
people have thought and so it's not
clear Scotland's gonna go first of all
and then secondly yeah Northern Ireland
definitely won't go but what's happening
in Northern Ireland is yeah the unionist
vote it probably even more than the
English to leave so I would love to see
the breakdown but it's gonna be quite
strongly brexit amongst the Protestants
right then the Catholics would have
voted almost unanimously for me so that
and the proper reason there is 50/50
right it's about 50/50 it's may be
slightly more Protestants still some
Protestants would have voted remain
because there's the strong agricultural
industry there which relies on EU
subsidies and Protestant farmers and
interest would have voted to remain for
that reason now the other thing of
course is that there's a right now an
open border because both countries
everything you that would no longer be
open however a lot of all people in
Northern Ireland are eligible for an
Irish passport so they may a lot of
people are trying to get these passports
just so that they have unfettered access
to the EU including Protestants staunch
unionists so unis so it's part of the
view they're you know some Irish
nationalists are thinking oh well this
is kind of united Ireland through the
backdoor if if all the of Northern
Ireland takes up Irish citizenship yeah
but then the others worry that there's
gonna be what's called a hard
which means kind of sport checks and
customs checks on the border which is
symbolically seen by the Irish
nationalists as an impediment to
unification of Ireland right and the
last point then since you mentioned a
Spain and made this little further from
your area of expertise what's the
likelihood that something will happen in
Gibraltar because the Gibraltar cars
voted overwhelmingly in favor of remain
I mean they're just across the border
the same situation as in Ireland yet the
one of the major arguments that Britain
has always used why they don't want to
give up Gibraltar is it the people
they're overwhelmingly want to remain a
part of remain a part of the UK and now
the European Union will be presumably
quite supportive of any Spanish effort
to change the status of Gibraltar in
some way have you any sense of what
might happen there I don't know I don't
have a good sense of that I mean part of
it will depend on the deal because
what's there's something called article
50 which is once Britain gives notice to
the EU right attention to leave then
they have a two-year window in which to
negotiate a deal they don't want to sort
of give them that notice because that
then that puts Britain under under the
gun right so what's gonna I think happen
is there's going to be jockeying to and
fro so that the outlines of a proposed
deal will emerge hopefully in the next
you know six months or so and that once
the outlines of a deal is there then the
financial markets and so on will get a
bit more certainty and then Britain will
then proceed to it to negotiate but what
might happen therefore is Gibraltar will
still see what the outlines of this deal
are if they include more or less free
movement then and more or less free
trade than maybe Gibraltar will be not
that affected so maybe that will then
count them down so that's the current
thing all right
okay super I'm gonna end the stay on the
line we can chat some more yeah thank
you I think that's really great and yeah
thank you okay
all right thanks I should yeah I should
just point out that
this discussion will be transcribed and
will be available as a lesson at link
for those people whose language you know
native language isn't English so they
can use this I think very interesting
discussion you've you know provided a
lot of clarity and they can also improve
their English by studying it at link so
bye for now